The Joe Rogan experience. Cause I,
I went from football to strong man and in football we'd never done dead lifts.
It was all hang cleans and power cleans. Which by the way,
just quick little tip dead lifts the fear,
if you're dead lifting to be about a dead lift are fine.
If you're not doing that for deadlifts sake, then don't fucking do it.
The risk to reward ratio is a joke for deadlift, for deadlifts.
And a lot of people aren't gonna like that. I'm saying that.
But if you go into any NFL gym in any division, one college football gym,
in any athletics where people are actually getting paid and it matters what
they're doing, they're not dead lifting their hand clean in a power cleaning.
Why is that? Because the, the risk reward ratio, like there's,
it's so hard to be a great dead lifter and to not rescue low back and, uh,
to be using your upper back properly and you know, just there's so many little,
uh, um, chances for you to get hurt, you know, hamstring stuff. That was,
that was me. Uh, my first world's strongest men.
I was the only rookie in the finals, Perot, China. How much weight is that?
That was 880 pounds for me and my pink chucks.
And you're way less than that now. I'm less of a bowling ball though.
Really? Wow. The, well, they made those waits.
Ridiculous looking too,
right? Well, nothing. That right there is something we overhead press too,
so they'll take some of the weights out of it and it's so flimsy when you clean
it,
it's like basically like holding that earthquake bar that you have out there.
It's just like that and it's, it's fucking brutal. Disneyland
on Instagram the other day,
dudes are going out on Disneyland and this one guy punched a check to see people
feminine to people were filming it in.
These people were throwing down in front of their kids at Disneyland.
Terrible technique too. Everybody's terrible. Terrible. I love that. The
equally disappointing aspect of it. Oh, it's terrible.
It's the most disappointing. It's like guys, if you're kind of find,
it's just learn some technique. Yeah.
I mean it's like someone's stealing the stage and playing a bad guitar.
You'd be angry when. Yeah, sure. Of course. See what I'm saying? Yeah, I get it.
No, I'm, I'm in complete agreement.
I think that that is kind of equally important because, hey man,
if people are filming, yeah, people would like a consensual fight.
You look like you're trying to pretend you know how to fight. Yeah. And the,
the the worst is the pulling off of the shirt.
I don't even know how that even becomes like an indistinct.
It's actually a good move. Well it's to keep you slippery, right?
So you can like, well you want, yeah.
You don't want anybody choking you to death with your own jacket.
Oh that's true. Yeah, that's true. Oh, okay.
But I mean I guess in the videos that I've seen, it's been mostly about like,
hey check, she's jacked. I am. And like, yeah, yeah.
I kinda looked like this dude got choked out but I couldn't quite tell what's
going on here.
Cause he went down quick cause that's security and he might even been off for a
second. So he's pulling that girl's hair. See? Oh yeah, he's all cold. Cold.
Oh, you dropped him. His head banged off the ground to that ball.
Dude choked the shit out. And he's like, well, I just killed that guy.
I better get out of here. But yeah. No one ever choked.
No charges were pressed because no one wanted to say what the fight was about.
Hilarious was that.
So it was a guy that was holding a girl's hair at the, he was gay. He got sick,
he got spit on and then he went crazy. Oh Wow.
I don't know if that was say a whole thing. Not Funny. That's all.
It takes a little bit of water. A little bit of, yeah. It's funny. It's,
I got all the things that make people go crazy spit in someone's face.
It's like, wow, we were ready to go to war here. Yeah. I mean it's,
it is pretty quick not approved biological weapon back in the day.
If you had some like smallpox or some shit. Yeah.
Like how dare you potentially infect me.
There was this thing with vox where Carlos Mesa was a
men minimizing, um, the,
the impact of Antifa and kinda joking around about it.
And making it seem like it's just no big deal.
And he got really upset because Steven Crowder was making fun of the fact that
he's gay.
And the fact that he talks with the list and that Crowder mentioned that along
with mocking his stance on Antifa and then it became this gigantic thing that
Steven Crowder's gay basher.
But what didn't become a big deal is that this guy is minimizing violent
fascists. And that's what I mean. That's how I feel about this.
When you're trying to enforce your own ideology on other people and you have no
tolerance for anybody with a differing opinion, particularly journalists,
that is fascism.
It's so ironic to call yourself an antifascist when you're literally enforcing
your own particular ideology to the point of violence and you're wearing masks
and you're running around hitting people and pretending that you're being
inundated with Nazis and white supremacists and that this is all necessary.
Like that old man that was just driving and they're directing traffic and
forcing him to abide, obey them, and then when he doesn't want to,
they chase after him and assault him. It's fucking bananas.
And the fact that this city has not stepped in and recognize that they have a
real problem because this has got momentum behind it and the people that are
involved that are nonviolent. You got to speak up. They've got to speak up.
If you're a person that really believes that there shouldn't be homophobia and
there shouldn't be violence and there shouldn't be white supremacy,
good for you. You probably got involved in this for all the right reasons,
but if you don't recognize that someone like you yourself who is a person of a
different ethnicity, you're not a white person. You're Vietnamese,
you're a gay man and you've got assaulted for no reason.
You didn't do anything that mean.
It's almost like a test of where do your values truly lie.
And if you think it's okay for a person like you to just get assaulted for no
reason, you are the problem. You're the problem.
You're mindset is the problem.
It's not whether or not there should be white supremacy.
Of course there shouldn't be.
It's not whether or not there shouldn't be people be able to freely express
themselves. Of course should be. That is not what the issue is.
What the issue is is group mob mentality.
When you get people together and you let them wear masks and you tell them that
they're fighting against some evil and then they feel justified in hitting a
person like you, it,
it is really sickening and there's this diffusion of responsibility thing that
happens when one person hits you and everybody feels like it's okay to hit you.
It's a mob mentality thing and it's, it is extremely common with human beings.
I've, I've been in mob situations,
it's terrifying because you feel it in the air.
You feel the chaos in the air when you're in some sort of a a large scale brawl
type situation like anything can happen.
People just run up on people and start punching them.
It's not like two people alone in a, in a,
in the like an open area where they can talk and work things out. No,
it's chaos and there's some weird animal activity.
There's some weird weird animal instinct aspect to it that is very unique to
humans and when you see something like this and see a guy like you just getting
peppered with milkshakes and punched in the head and it's fucking disturbing.
And for these people to dismiss that and not stand out, not stand up and say,
hey, this is not what we're supposed to be about.
This is not what I signed up for. They become a part of the problem.
I'm sure there's people listening to this that are upset at this because maybe
you, you, you've support Antifa you support their ideology.
Think about what you actually support.
Think about what this is really all about.
What you shouldn't be supporting is people wearing masks,
running around fucking hitting people. You ain't changing shit with that.
All you're going to do is call for more people with masks from the other side.
If people feel like right wing people are being attacked and I don't think
you're even right wing, are you? I mean, what are, what will you, what would,
if you had a gun to your head or a mace to your face, what would you just say?
You're a centrist, what would you say?
I think it's fair to describe me as center. Right. Center. Right. Okay.
Which is fine. It should be okay. I mean, there should be,
we should be allowed to have disagreements of ideologies and of political
persuasions, political leanings. But this is,
it's twisted and it's twisted. The way it's being depicted in the media.
It's very strange how it's being dismissed. It's very strange.
And that there's really people in 2019 debating whether or not it's okay to
assault journalists. Jorge Mossville, Mazda Dao,
where he said after the fight,
but he said he would smack him if he saw him at whole foods. I think,
I think it's just a little too much. You want, I, I,
I don't know their history. The history is rough. [inaudible] excuse me.
It's like 10 years of them. Uh, given him a hard time of if I'm, uh,
Ben asking, given miles, but all corn to Mazda doll, a lot of talking shit,
which some people think is friendly in Moundsville Wall Street.
Jesus doesn't fuck around. All right. You want to talk shit.
You want to shit to street Jesus.
He will fucking make fun of you after he flat lines here.
And that's what he did. He flat lined him in five seconds,
made him the fastest ever Kao in UFC history and then mocked him afterwards and
said he would smack him if he saw him at whole foods.
But see we're talking about it. So Mazda is smart. This is a,
this is an amazing marketing ploy. I mean he's,
he's become in one fight the most talked about fighter in the sport
because he did something in the sport that's been around for a little bit that
nobody's ever done before. Yeah.
He was undefeated,
undefeated and Mazda doll comes out flat lines like that and talk some pretty
vicious shit after the fact and even mimicked him laying on the floor,
which looks scary the way he was out.
[inaudible] yeah. Mazda doll will say, Ahhh, calls out easy.
Conor McGregor. I want to break his face. Yeah, that would be,
that's a rough fight. That's a rough fight for Connor mas.
Woodall was a big fellow too. I mean he's,
he really belongs at one 70 that's where he's fighting.
He fought at one 55 but really tortured himself to make that weight. Right.
He's a big guy.
You're talking about a guy who knocked out cowboys Serone knocked out Darren
till knocked out Ben Asprin.
I mean he's knocking out big welterweights big Darren till's a big welterweight.
He's big. He's not a guy coming up from 155 pounds.
He's never making 150 copies. Weight 55 one 55 sorry. Yeah,
so he's one way class heavier and he's really running into like the last few
fights. He's coming into his own. He's like really becoming something special.
He had a real close, uh, decision loss to Wonderboy.
Wish I could remember how that fight went down,
but I just think it was a decision.
I don't know if it was a split decision or unanimous decision,
but I think it was just Wonderboy out pointed them.
I don't think there was any knockdowns right? No smiles with, oh yeah,
that was monster doll.
But Wonderboy is a particularly difficult guy to fight and especially for three
rounds.
And I went to Bali right after,
cause I have some flown island friends and I stay out there for a week.
That's an amazing place. That's a place I want to go to. Flies, Bali luck.
Cause I almost went there last summer we decided to go to Thailand instead.
But have you served before? No. It's a, it's scared.
It's a great place for surfing. You're not scared of sharks? No.
Oh No. Shark yesterday. No. Don't do this to Jamie.
25 to 30 feet long. 5,000 pounds. Wow. What? Yeah,
like jaws is real straight. Tell us is real the biggest shark ever, right?
It's gotta be what did, when did this get soft? Someone said it to me yesterday,
I remember watching on my phone.
And you just like set it and it popped right in my head.
What's the biggest shark ever?
It's like the Shaq of human beings for the sharpish.
Put exaggerating those numbers, but that's what it says here. Here's the tweet.
What is this from Twitter? Twitter. Martha's vineyard shows does exist.
Watch how big fucking thing is. Okay, here go.
There's the tail right here. Martha's vineyard. Isn't that split? It was, yeah.
Oh my God. Dude, it's so big. Oh my God. Wow.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
That is so big. Do you not just fuck with people who are that big? It's hard.
Perspective wise, does numbers could be slightly exaggerate. Listen that,
that 25 to 30 feet, 5,000 pounds. How do you know who's saying this?
Who's posting this? Uh, what is this Gregory Long. Oh, does he do, I don't know.
I'll look up. And what do you do, Gregory? What is this?
What is his actual credentials at that? He's doesn't seem to be a sharp guy,
but it's his Wednesday wisdom. How's that wisdom? Ah, Greg,
what are you talking about, Greg? The drunk guy. Great. You drop it.
Find out though. Greg's drunk at work. That might've just been 15 feet.
It might be a regular grape. Either way. It's fucking giant.
Might not have been really 21 in Hawaii that they monitor. Right.
They have a chip and it's called like deep blue or big blue or something like
that. Something like that. Yeah. And that's the biggest one that know of.
Correct. Yeah, but I thought that was significantly smaller. Like 20 feet. Yeah.
This is on a bunch of websites. Ran this story. Oh, okay.
What Twitter user. Gregory Long posted a video.
But there's no perspective though. It's,
there's not a boat that you can look at. We can say, oh, this is a 15 foot boat.
Look at it's 10 feet longer than the boat. Yeah. Come on Greg.
Stop being drunk at work.
Either way. Fuck sharks, man.
[inaudible].